i had a constructive and useful phone
call with prime minister boris johnson
we discussed the major unsolved topics
our negotiation teams have been working
day and night over the
recent days and despite
the exhaustion after almost one year of
negotiations
and despite the fact that deadlines have
been missed over and over
we both think that it is responsible
at this point in time to go the extra
mile
we have accordingly mandated our
negotiators to continue the talks
and to see whether no reach an agreement
can be reached
even at this late stage
the negotiations continue here in
brussels
thank you so much
well there she is uh ursula von der line
the
european commission president very short
statement wasn't it
uh some of the key words were useful and
constructive that phone call
that we know has happened with boris
johnson uh this morning
we have agreed she said to go the extra
mile ordered
the negotiators on both sides to
continue discussions
and signals there that a deal is
possible
from ursula von de line even as she says
at
this late stage so uh
very interesting uh let's bring sam
coats back in there very interesting
what she had to say that was it has to
be said the kind of mood music coming
uh from brussels uh this morning sam and
amazing what a few hours does
given all this pessimism on both sides
last night
absolutely we've got some more for you
just now uh downing street have released
a joint statement between boris johnson
and ursula uh vandalism let me read it
to you
uh now i suspect it'll sound quite
similar to what uh slavonda line just
uh told us in front of the tv cameras
they say together
we had a useful phone call this morning
we discussed the major
unresolved topics our negotiating teams
have been working day and night over
recent days and despite the exhaustion
after almost a year of negotiations
despite the fact
that deadlines have been missed over and
over we think it is responsible at this
point to go the extra mile
we have accordingly mandated our
negotiators to
continue the talks and to see whether uh
an agreement uh
can even at this late stage be reached
so
those words that have been agreed
jointly very much uh what you just heard
come out of
ursula van der lion's mouth i would
expect uh boris johnson to
take to the tv cameras very very soon
almost certainly
uh to use identical words uh to those as
well
but the key thing is first of all the
tone which is a world away from the
british only statement that we had at
nine o'clock last night to remind you
just a little bit of
uh what that language sounded like last
night uh we were saying
the uh number ten sources were saying as
things stand the offer on the table
from the eu remains unacceptable uh the
agreement must be fair and respect the
fundamental
position of the uk uh that will be a
sovereign nation in three weeks time
none of that negative language evident
in the joint statement
just now which talks about useful and
constructive
dialogue